yeah hello and welcome to yet another
session of some blitz games I think
we're going to we're going to go blitz
games right
hey could okay bye no I keep doing one
of those classical games like 15 plus 50
like and let's do that why not let's do
something relaxing
it's immensely hot this team Wow
that actually valid expression probably
not here but I think you're getting the
point I am not actually getting a game
with this time control and I have to
reconsider I give it a moment
that doesn't look like it
I'll get one in spooky new with the
black pieces so
my rating is kind of provisional here
with a question mark
is he playing actually
hmm look market
I mean you have 20-something seconds for
the first move and even does not
actually start the clock so yeah it's
kind of a non now he plays crazy
okay so let's play c5 inviting a
Sicilian
is probably not going to heat is
happening okay interesting
okay so the open soil
you
yeah of course I'm going to go for on
this fashion akov did not study it and
write this course
fight like Magnus course and then I'm
not playing it it's not not happening
okay so let's see what line is going for
the D fashionable 95
he's taking quite a bit of time
on basically forced and obvious moves
like it takes t5 if you are playing this
variation you kind of
I can pre move that well but okay maybe
he's just taking a long time because
he's got time 15 plus 15 is a very
galets that's a reasonably long time
control now you can really think about
this for more in particular the 15
seconds that's really a lot now you see
that I started with 15 and I've gotten a
good chunk of additional time because I
was able to play almost instantly
of course this is all well known
theoretically
castle now
you
this very little point in playing
something else sometimes white has the
idea to play the move c5 intending to
answer the capture with the six okay
it's taking a long time to come up with
Queen age five hmm that is a somewhat
surprising move because I have g6 which
is a reasonable reply and even f5 and I
think I'm going f5 because f5 is part of
my um my am strategic a program let's
say anyway and g6 this is not so clear
this is something that I want to do for
sure okay so he went f3
yeah that's really a bit odd to play the
Queen out to age five and then continue
with f3
this is stopping the e pawn
but it definitely also has some
drawbacks one drawback is the weakening
of them of the dark squares in
particular
yeah those squares f23 they are severely
weakened an idea that I'm wondering
about is to place the Queen to b6
on b6 to be sixes weird English
[Music]
get immediate Queen b6
you might have a 45
you
I am really interested in preventing him
from castling the move Queen b6 is
really quite annoying mm-hmm I just
wonder about the timing
now Queen b6 I think a four a five could
be yeah but even then there are African
Oh Kim so
if we if one looks annoying
a four a five I can go to see five but
somehow this doesn't feel quite right
you
there also is
way to cream be six a four I can play a
five actually
eight-six Bishop d7 yes that's better
let's do this
one idea that white maybe has is g-form
in this kind of position the idea of
courses I cannot take because I'm
getting mated on h7e Alec yeah so he's
going for this now I cannot take on G
form that me do this because Bishop age
seven leads to mate
Bishop age 7 King edge 8 Bishop g6 check
is mate however it's hard to believe
that this approach here can work because
I have the movie form
and this is the kind of thing that in a
blitz game I would have already put it
on the board it must be the writing
somehow yeah let's do it this is not
right something is really off him
F takes and now I could take on g4 and
if I'm ready for is with the tempo so I
take it on before and then Queen have to
check this is the thing
my queen on b6 as gap is well placed
still I have the check on f2 King D 1
and what next this is really not totally
obvious to me
you
yeah I have this check but what wants to
do after it
it's kind of it's a little bit pointless
to spend time on this because I have to
play this anyway more or less
now what now so I can give this check
and this is probably going to be right
No
is it possible that I have something
else like on g6 white can simply take on
g6
this is of course a problem him
[Music]
you
so let's do this first and
think about this there are a couple of
very interesting points here one is dead
after g6 Bishop takes g6 I have Queen f3
check
so quite important
I'm not certain that it helps all that
much
he goes king c2
hmm
I don't really ever good reply
you
you
you
age six he's got
Queen g6 which is not that much of a
threat
I have who gave six for example are not
immediately losing
so very strange this whole thing
you
I kind of
basically relied on
I just hoped let's say that I've got
something now
currently don't see anything good
I mean g6 takes on g6 as a draw
which it's not great I don't want to
draw
[Music]
show
but I don't quite see how to avoid it
mr. age six looks mentally risky
it's not even clear that I have a good
reply against Bishop takes h6
amazing
you
hmm yeah g6 Bishop takes Queen f3 but
King City where don't there's just
nothing I can go to e2 I will check on
it too and I just don't just don't have
anything there
it's remarkable as it sounds
you
you
you
Jim I don't see anything good him
six Bishop checks I mean I might even
lose this right he's got Queen h5 check
in the sequence
you know I think you have to do this I
mean it's kind of not exactly what I
wanted to do it
so I check on ff3 is there anything that
I can do
just don't see and
yeah I wonder if there's some win
offering me a draw and this is
impossible to refuse there was an odd
game yeah but I I don't think I could
actually deviate yeah that it's very
strange actually
so after g-form I mean it it just it
just seems to be losing but I did not
see I didn't see how so it seems like a
six is basically winning
so the reason is probably that I have
something good here yeah now Queen d4 is
very strong
yeah okay what efore now
and then insert this one yeah it did
it's really not possible that g4 can be
good that just isn't doesn't really do
um just isn't really should work so II
for and in fact the problem is that I
played F takes e4 much too quickly much
too quickly I should play a6 first okay
yeah and then something like this FG six
and then I can take here intending this
one so it's really the case I kind of
yeah trusted my intuition that I have
something here in fact I don't I just
don't and here I basically have to go
for this as H six Bishop takes h 6 H 6
is completely devastating that that
can't work I saw I I looked at this but
I couldn't really make it work if you
check it couldn't be true I think even
Bishop h7 works right yeah I saw that
line yeah this is the thing
and Wow hey you can go here but that
also won't work out probably due to this
there are many ways to lose this so I
have to with g6 I basically have to call
the clock you can actually think about
whites trying to play for win here maybe
there is something that he can try the
engine doesn't show any any win like a
straightforward win
Bishop d2 something like this to play
Knight to d7 mm-hmm yeah this is still a
game I mean I understand that he is
happy with the draw of being 400 points
the underdog but white could have
continued for sure it's not it's not
clear that I'm betting or anything you
know the engine actually evaluates this
is a roughly equal position okay that
was interesting a bit of a bit of a
short game but it had interesting
content nevertheless so yeah maybe you
have five plus three if we can get it
yeah this a form F efe I played this too
quickly assembly relied on my feeling
that I would find something that
something is there but it just wasn't
anything
Kame seems difficult Jim but okay we had
a longer game already maybe we can get a
three plus two
Maria yaki MOBA had actually a real
person
like it's obviously a real person but I
mean this is the right name
Caze so we've got a Catalan attempt
I've tried many things him let's take
this is a solid approach
you
you
I'm very actively played with 93 what
assume that I can take this now because
there is no way to
get c4 back quickly but white doesn't
care she just plays it in gambit style
okay
yeah that is certainly possible my dark
squares are weak but I have
have the pawn
and to play a quick c-5m
yeah I think before
seems good I can't play Bishop a
six-year always to cover the pawn in
fact this is even giving my bishop some
relatively active square
we should a six and potentially c3
yeah I think this looks quite okay
actually
what is whites brilliant idea here I
don't quite see it you can play c5 here
even trying to get rid of this pawn
it's what you want to do so let's play
the move
one interesting point is that this I
thought isn't good due to c3 but why did
not
dress this so I'm playing c3
give up the pawn anyway and why not push
it forward um yeah I think pawn takes
yeah establish the pawn on c3 looks good
and honestly I don't see
White has a disposition for a pawn
so let's go Ruby too
I also had night before bird
wouldn't quite
oh yeah I came so after the capture he
wants to go 94 I guess
you can't play what could be too old so
yeah okay this is not a bad
still there is rook Ruby to 193
ninety-three more or less for sister
the exchange sacrifice but yes she has
knight c6 to get it back
yeah okay I'm not going to spend more
time let's do this
you should you should just okay this is
possible of course it's not bad actually
okay so take this first and then I'm
taking this one and now knight c6 this
is interesting because
it is not
completely obvious where I should be
going
mean d7 or c7
[Music]
unfortunately after night ticks
I can also go to g5
five sting there is F form
you know it doesn't really help
okay em so let's do this
there are some interesting tactical
points in this position one thing is
that after night b8
just recognize that I have the move
Bishop c4
and then potentially
okay
isn't that's good
warm
in 66
under one
I'm just Oh
this is this is passive but I just had
this sound but the time was running
running low and this cost me to panic a
little bit
just recognize okay let's play a move
now and better do it fast
you
yeah it's not ideal which again you have
to sometimes just make a move
take on c4 chick and f6 now
which is for sure reasonable
[Music]
not sure why Quinby to was played but
I'm going to make sure to keep the pawn
I'm an exchange up I mean
she doesn't even have a pawn
you
yeah and the night is not very dangerous
in fact
that's just as I mentioned this I run
into this friggin Fork
okay
you
when young it's still
Jewish
you
you know it is very dry
mmm not happy about this I should win I
should have won this game I was pretty
much completely winning
not varied not difficult actually
as summer also spent too much time there
you
and it's pretty much withdrawn no matter
what
you
no don't take this
I had a very similar endgame [ __ ]
some days ago
there's just just a complete wrong
unfortunately in some way I would have
liked to do - in this game but wasn't
quite possible
I mean it was possible but I didn't
manage is what I'm trying to say
you
hmm it's a bit annoying actually okay so
I'm giving this up still a draw
yeah people ah not really a game that I
like
and so entirely unnecessary to get into
something like this
yes she's going on g6 now
so it's really not
much happening
you
and fortunately there's very little that
white can do wrong it's just like white
can continue this forever and ever
[Music]
you
yeah it would have been good not to
give up the air porn but sometimes it's
unavoidable in such a in such a scenario
and wonder if I'm screwing this up I'm
not doing this really well
I think I could have been
sighs them
you
now king of
I think
but it's getting
getting a bit annoying
you
not sure that I had to do the King walk
you
I think she basically has trapped her
own look there
yeah and now I can draw by somebody
taking them
you
yeah not so happy here I should just win
the game based on the the way it went
but yeah sometimes doesn't work out as
you wanted to unfold just not precise
enough
yeah I play a rematch
you
yeah this line is some not very popular
for black the reason is that order the
reason is that it is pretty dangerous
for black this is one of the lines that
can easily lead to very disastrous
we'll see how it unfolds the problem
here is very much tactical as this is
never going to work or I mean it it you
can play it but it's just not good
because of this idea
now after night move I have Queen a4 and
pick up the night
so why does getting
getting good wood pieces
missus I can
hardly believed long-term that this
would work now my thread is 95
we immediately here
so she prevented this one
how to do this yeah maybe maybe go for
quick development yeah what's
development yes pretty strong
you
okay um
yeah maybe just night to see form
or to e4 maybe
PAH
you
hard to believe that you can play all
that
I don't quite
see our punishment real decisive
punishment
hmm
okay
you
that is possible
okay yeah and I have to make sure that
I'm just not losing on time because I
like every move I should have something
that kills black and then you just lose
on time you think it can happen
you
okay now night you form
this is really possible huh
there shouldn't there be some kind of
tactic that that kills black like on d6
or something doesn't seem to be the case
sometimes chess is a strange game
go to d1 I hope that I was a mouse slip
maybe not a fatal one
Wow I'm not winning this game I'm going
to be really really really really
annoyed
f-five you serious
how can then ever work
you
okay now
kuna three yet it doesn't look
completely winning and probably missing
stuff all over the place in this game
494 looks terrible for blackbirds
doesn't look like
best
feels like blackest somehow in the game
which is kind of amazing
No
I don't see how she keeps the six but
the bishop on g5 is of course also a
little bit a little bit loose
stern layer 56
with the tempo okay
you know that's just one one single
check on h2
and I have Queenie six Queen f5 and so
on
the rook cannot take due to currency aid
made
so probably the game
will ultimately end in my favor but
you never know where she played so many
shocking moves to me and there might be
another shock in store for me
okay yeah Queen f5
you have something better here
another check it's not
not clear how I'm home winning here
right
you
no I don't I don't see a flat-out win
amazingly this and here maybe this one
ship f5
that looks good
you
Bishop f5
or can that not be made it's really so
crazy
you
just I just need to look on the edge
file for Christ's sake and I don't see
how I get there
it's really amazing
you
don't see move Jesus this is just a
blunder right come on
maybe it
somehow
only got a couple of seconds
you
seven seconds
yeah I blundered this friggin game I
cannot believe it this is just a joke of
a game
my queen is hand i completely completely
lost the plot IAM
by winning on time
this is a blend of the Queen and this is
just the oddest game ma'am I mean I was
probably there was so much winning and I
couldn't figure it out I mean I actually
wonder wondered about the opening that
that like somehow was still in the game
I'm probably just playing this like a
complete [ __ ]
so yeah g5 was maybe stronger but still
I can't believe this at all I mean not
at all h5 is incredible
like you have no development nothing and
you play h5 and okay it is like +3 yet
you still have to have to do it Queen a
form
you know probably for a quick attack on
c6 like 95 stuff
but there are many moves that win but
not not the one that I played f5 is
crazy
it's crazy and I cannot I'm just too
stupid to review that yeah I mean okay
am i plus four looks kind of good but
I'm just not able to win this game it's
crazy
so this and now Knight g3 plus 20i for
Bishop we form
yeah that's not exactly difficult but
okay this is probably also plus plus a
lot I couldn't get it to work yeah crazy
so Knight f7 I completely lost the plot
here with the clock ticking down
I have six is just ridiculous but III
didn't see anything I mean it was just
like stunned here so I can take c6 so
yeah it's kind of anything winds just
not this and then yeah all hell break
loose no breaks loose and I still win
with Bishop f8 because my queen is
actually covered I mean okay I didn't
see anything there just just nothing a
Bishop g5 wins yeah it was this was the
most awful game that you can imagine I'm
actually surprised if she look at de
well that it's not like - a million
after all the double question mark moves
that I played but yeah i blundered the
queen just for episode 4 made it - and
then she over overstepped the time that
was crazy yeah I don't know I just
couldn't find anything reasonable in
that time scren scary scramble ok one
more one more game I guess hopefully a
better one than this one
so how can I get into this time I'm
pressure you know it's sometimes if
there are so many crazy moves played
your thing like okay come on at this
must be over immediately and then you
look at this and you don't see anything
sometimes you just have to make this
decision to just play quickly and just
say okay I'm opponent is playing some
sorry nonsense anyway just play quickly
and see that you don't overstep the time
and because you won't predict a move
anyway
yeah that sometimes it's just the case
so bit of a weird setup here my black
combination of a Catalan and guru felt
not something you see every day
I'm just going to try to develop you
know
and he's straightforward way
96 maybe 4 black looks good
forcing a commitment
yeah but b6 yeah I can play many things
yeah this is not one of them
lines that I had expected
yeah black will have to still work a bit
to get cc8 Bishop to good use
yes you can play Bishop be kept like b6
and we should be seven but this is still
probably going to be me
with every weakness won c-6
yeah that's it still playable like a
still quite solid
oh crap
so it's
I don't want a double ponder and the B
file him not under these circumstances
so ninety-two and opening up the
diagonal is probably not such a bad idea
anyway with Queen b6 at least there must
be success outside it sides out of the
picture
and again b65 is not easy to play now
so be 6 but see 5 not easy
and okay the night on b3 is not
super useful
it does stop or it helps to stop c5 but
still
I need to
probably reposition this piece
see for possibly 95 or 96
you
do this
you
should've ate yep Percy five at
what you want to do him
it's taking a bit of time though
yeah now the move before this is always
a tough decision if you should play this
or not because it sometimes runs into a
five and all of a sudden the black the
dark squared Bishop that black has turns
into a very strong piece
it's a tough one tough decision
I'm doubling on the C file I mean I have
to be a bit aware of the of tactics here
No
no unprotected rook sometimes their
tactics are condensed if I were to move
like Roxy - but not now the idea now is
to go 95
you know I was kind of predictable and
now that you would do that now where do
we go
d2 is the most obvious square
still connecting to the e5 square
you
the most before gets a little bit more
interesting now I think before c5 I'm AI
can take a plane night
no one I know 95
okay so play the normal
okay let's do the snow
okay in 95 simply attacking c6 there's
no king d6 right Knight f7
it seems a bit annoying then what what
is he playing LAN rock d6 b5
why am i pulling the trigger too early I
don't think I am see five losses upon
and taking losses apiece
you
and I don't see any tactic here like
some
on the back Renoir something like that I
don't see anything I don't today it's
just nothing nothing available
you know let's just put it back
Knight c4 as a huge threat
oh okay
you
and I think 95 looks good
it's a check and trading more here is
really helpful
what is the technically best way to play
yeah just just take away all the squares
for the night
head with him
before this is probably fairly easy
everything is protected and I can now
simply March the king to before and get
the protected or get the passport not
protected
you're under greenside
I can now give up the exchange I just
wonder if there's any breakthrough idea
I'm quicker though
is six like f4 takes d4 I'm just not
quicker them
I always have to think about this
because you just win by just not
sacrificing so always be careful and
things like that if you know you're
going to win very easily without
anything fancy you just do it but this
is just
wins by made yeah tough game somehow
they defended this quite well I think
okay now oh it's not available I would
have gone for rematch so one more game I
guess for the session
coochi Hindley car wow that's a
complicated one made me see form
you
okay
it's a bit
an uncommon move on a let's say black is
going for him
White has a couple of options I'm going
to try something with b3 the setup has
become a little bit more popular in
recent in recent times
mmm okay I don't mind dad
III I want to play anyway so
that this helped like so I'm getting
basically to Tempe
or for nothing
hmm
she's just giving me the bishop Pam
Oh bleep oh nice
[Music]
I don't want dad
what
how does that work
so I'll take it
efore
yeah I'm not going to
just
you've back up on down
very odd game a black
a single night a 6e you just you cannot
sacrifice a piece in this position
I would be really strange
yeah and I'm grabbing this pawn
you
yeah I'm calling up 85 maybe was
possible
okay stop sit but not not a problem if I
still have a great position maybe I
should have played e5 because that is a
there was a kind of a one time
opportunity
how do we how do we win this position
probably
yummmm have to think about this for
moment I think I'm going to reposition
this to e3 look b1 play for B form this
looks good
I mean I'm just a pawn up or not much
a black is probably going for night 24
right
hmm
I have the idea to play F for birds this
has to be well prepared
okay I'm not unhappy about this
because with the c5 pawn out of the way
there's just a higher probability to
ever play d4 at some stage um yeah
probably he will just play ninety form
and I never get them
interesting
okay this is also possible let's do it
now this I can just take 97 was
necessary
we have an odd game so one more we can
do one more make it a good hour in this
video
/ some tea left
amazingly it's still somewhat somewhat
hard
UST asked Cayman okay I've got white so
I should play actually
you
good line for black getting them
um yeah grabbing the pawn and
now this I'm a bit skeptical about
Bishop d7 and Bishop c6 because
White has good chances here to occupy
the center and black has very little to
show for that
near the sea porn here is blocked it's
not involved in the central struggle and
if I managed to play
interesting I managed to play D Phi D 4
I'm definitely better
ah interesting north
you
yeah c'mon it's no use to spend even
more time
yeah a five is a that sometimes call
like a whatever move when you when
you're faced with the move like that is
they okay whatever let's just play
okay now
stay a way to punish black here with
this ought configuration somehow his
next move could be b6
I wonder if I have a way to address this
one possibility is a e5 was let's do
this that gains a lot of space and I
have 95 in some cases in particular
against b6 95 is going to be a pretty
awkward move to face
and it's not bad anyway establishing
this huge
on chain the pollen e5 is particular
looking at d6 + f6 limiting black
severely what is he doing here
locate with Bishop d5 or Bishop b5
okay so
this
porky 4g4 later
Wow
he really thinks that he's got all the
time in the world
maybe he maybe this is right but it
would be a bit surprising
you
okay I'm going for this simply intending
queen c1 and smash on age six
I think 95 I just go back to the two and
I'm happy about it
I also of course have this night h2g for
idea like this but I don't want the
trade on g2
one one attempt oh here right
if I go queen c1 is going to play King
age seven
that much is clear okay
I'm going to fix this pawn
you
how do we do this
in c1 King age seven I don't really have
a good answer to that
you
you
yeah I mean I like my position but I
don't see anything antastic that I can
do
this is just a
and idea
okay
watch is slow actually
you
far too slow this is also not for not
great
you
are interesting
interesting way how he stopped any
sacrifice
you
you
okay
still some some danger here for blacks
Kings not
not going to be super easy
you
kingi six I have to check on age six
go to f5 to to f3 but
and see at least I'm not easily losing
on time that's
good to see so is giving me this one
always tricky here with the
Roxy three rook GA dismayed
oh let's made
variation of the Arabian made my
favorite meat
cannot stop your kid
so I'm not happy with this I think I
should have gotten something real out of
the position and not this kind of
whatever more or less random random win
at the very beginning that was certainly
a very good opening position so yeah I'm
sorry I don't want to do a rematch at
this moment
something like this looks pretty nice
okay the engine things black is
completely fine
interesting
so
twenty-seven
rook d8 Bishop d5 Quincy six yeah that's
definitely definitely an idea yeah and I
mean I didn't find anything you know
you
I'm still surprised that the engine says
black is better but I'm just a natural
optimist rookie two was kind of saying
okay I have no clue what I'm doing here
and we're now here this is definitely
fine for black
I've and yeah I just didn't know what to
do
this was certainly all fine you can
probably improve this for for black but
I don't think he did anything wrong I'm
fairly sure Queen g5 wasn't best yeah
and this is confirmed by the engine it
wants to play Queen d5 and just continue
and this is I think giving me a bit of
hope at least
even though it's still black as complete
as fine
this Wow even this is a huge advantage
okay III thought that maybe I have
enough counter play here but it's
absolutely not the case
94 just wins okay yeah probably because
he will takes you three and then a two
when everything is kind of falling apart
right yeah so this is winning pretty
easily
one one one thing that are so of course
is the seer which which should win
laughs not not so clear actually hafta
94 but okay yeah Matt 94 does win pretty
convincingly
I got nothing I can play
they like this and this is just not not
dangerous
he's just not going into and now this is
just winning
yeah
was a very very lucky break
Here I am actually okay
somewhat okay at least yeah 0.34 black
doesn't feel like I'm losing yeah I did
not find the right approach to this
position maybe I should not play e5
given given how the game went that that
seems to be the case here and the engine
is also confirming that I should not do
that of course you can just play it a
group B one rupee 1 C form I just
thought that if I've could be an
interesting attacking idea
I was clearly too much focused on b6
which is rubbish because I have 95 I
prevented that move but he does not need
to play b6 in this position of course
and particularly not after he 5 if I go
c4 he kind of has to play b6 at some
point yet just to get Bishop b7 and
potentially c5 and but I should just do
this just place he 4 and say okay I've
got this what do you have him yeah that
was a pretty bad strategic decision to
play e5 that is giving up basically the
whole advantage
interesting interesting interesting fact
of course I was aware that I'm giving up
squares but I thought with e5 and this
this kind of play would be would be
dangerous but it wasn't okay guys thanks
for watching